les succès historiques des réacteurs
sont une source d'inspiration pour les
nombreux joueurs de basketball de la
ville un sentiment de fierté
indescriptible envahi toronto askar
joueurs canadiens américains africains
et asiatiques les wafers représente la
ville reine aujourd'hui et tous les
torontois peuvent s'identifier
nous sommes une des villes les plus
cosmopolites du monde souligne-t-elle
rigaud djordje mendjeli à 19 ans il est
arrivé des philippines il ya six ans
avec ses parents en quête d'une vie
meilleure
pour m il s'est intéressé au basketball
une fois arrivé à toronto
c'est son moyen de s'évader et les
raptors eux ont été sa façon de
s'intégrer à sa nouvelle ville et de se
faire des amis
mx maker en trouvant des intérêts
communs
yasmine saïda 16 ans ses parents sont
originaires d'ethiopie elle aussi se
sent plus accepté grâce au basket ball
grâce aux raptors qui l'ont incité à
créer un groupe sportif pour jeunes
musulmanes
les ninjas bieber on se sent parfois
exclus dans notre société dit elle
mais ces moments sportifs historique que
les ape nous procure nous unissent nice
bastia est une véritable vedette à
toronto
super partisans des raptors depuis leur
première partie il ya 24 ans il n'a raté
aucune partie à domicile c'est ma
famille explique-t-il une famille
cependant loin d'être multi culturelle
au départ quand il était le seul cycle
dans les gradins
nabe bat ye a décidé d'essayer de
changer les mentalités et d'intéresser
les jeunes de tous les horizons ou
basketball michael et ses efforts et
ceux des raptors ont été soulignés l'an
passé toronto a reçu le prix du
basketball professionnel pour son
leadership en matière d'inclusion
champion de la diversité et bientôt
mettre de la nba
navx bhatia en est convaincu nous allons
remporter ce championnat ici devant tous
nos partisans promet-il et les torontois
veulent le croire ici philippe leblanc
radio canada toronto